possibly and it's not in a so far future
we may have a clear evidence that they
are alive on
some of this planet so far is quite
amazing that
we are on one of the systems that looks
pretty much different
from all the planet that we have found
so is it the reason why
they are live because we are different
or
it's just a matter of luck here and i
think this kind of question we should be
able to answer
[Music]
so pete we've been really lucky on the
show because we've had some pretty
incredible guests right
yeah yeah i mean just uh top of my mind
we can can count bill nye a couple times
the science guy friend of the show
michio kaku yes a couple times
science communicator uh emily
calendrelli was a fun one uh we had dr
ranke
olabizi who taught us uh better how uh
to live in space
yes which is you know kind of where
we're gonna end up today we're not
living in space but we will be talking
about space
but we have not had a nobel prize winner
have we
are we having one today we are pete oh
this is good
it's it's really exciting for this show
because oh i mean a it's really cool to
have somebody that's obviously
accomplished something like that but you
know we've discussed exoplanets on the
show what five times ten
we're all going to have to go somewhere
so the the fun what if is to like think
about how we're going to go somewhere
and maybe get to an exoplanet
it's it's a new era the the new
frontiers as they used to say in star
trek but
you know not long ago we've discussed
that number people generally say over
4 000 exoplanets but 25 years ago there
were none
we had not discovered any exoplanets
except
our guest today and his team were the
people that in 1995 were the
discoverers of that very first exoplanet
that's created this entire new era
of cosmological astronomical research
that's
not just exciting people in the field
it's exciting everybody in the world
because it does feel like we're sort of
going into that next frontier of human
exploration it's wildly exciting yeah
and we're super honored to have
uh nobel prize winning astronomer didier
quello
join us today on what if discussed
professor how are you welcome to what
i've discussed
i'm fine thank you for the invitation
it's great to have you and again
as as peter and i were talking about
exoplanets have been a big part of many
conversations we've had
on this show before we get into sort of
the big what ifs
uh we're all sort of excited to hear
about
your excitement that day that fateful
day i mean it's it's hard to even
put it into words what it would be like
making a discovery like that
take us back to that day that moment and
what that was like
well i think we were not expecting to
find a planet like that
so it came up really at a big surprise
it was not part of my program
to detect this so i really believe
that was anything else but the planet
first when i saw the data
but after battling with the data i came
up with this very bizarre conclusion
there must be a planet like jupiter with
a very short orbit
and at that time it was absolutely a
crazy statement
my phd advisor didn't believe you right
away
he had it took him some month to really
realize that i was right
and i think it took clearly a couple of
years for the community to really
swallow this baby it was
really difficult to believe that
the very reason is the planet was like
jupiter but was orbiting the star
way closer than the orbit of mercury it
was really a roasted jupiter that's why
we call them a hot jupiter
and this kind of planet doesn't exist in
the solar system
and they even not predicted by the
theory it's even worse than that the
predicted the theory tell you it must
not exist
so the first planet to be found orbiting
another star
was indeed a planet that should have
never existed
but there are plenty wow well i'm
guessing there's a range of criteria too
and
that not all exoplanets are the same so
what what are the key attributes to
becoming an exoplanet or to qualify as
one
well i think we we started to find the
most obvious one with the technique we
had which is looking for
variability in the velocity of the stars
you can also pick planet if the planet
goes right in front of the star
it's called transits now
essentially what is a planet is is
something orbiting a star
which is of the mass of a planet like we
know so if you have anything like a
jupiter of a neptune of earth orbiting a
star
well it qualify as a planet and you
really understand
that this object must have formed
somewhat
from a structure that we call a
protoplanetary disk
and the origin of the formation of this
planet into the disk
should tell you something about the
nature of the planet and the chemistry
of the planet
and the possible atmosphere you may have
on this planet
yeah wildly exciting stuff we're going
to take a quick break we'll be back more
with professor kello
on the other side you are watching and
listening
to what if discussed richard let's talk
about
healthy eating kids let's okay well i've
been uh
hearing a lot about green chef recently
and i think it might be the best one out
there
green chef is the first usda certified
organic meal company they make
eating well easy and affordable with
plans to fit every lifestyle so whether
you're
keto or paleo vegan vegetarian
some people are just looking to eat
healthier well they've got recipes to
suit
any diet or preference well and that's
the key right now obviously we know sort
of these food delivery services are
blown up
but we don't want to sort of start
eating unhealthy and everybody getting
off their whether it's paleo whether
it's keto the fact that you can now get
that delivered
you know quality but also the ability to
make it easier
uh you know i think it's it goes without
saying it's huge
yeah i think it's gonna stick around too
i think it's a really important and if
you're thinking it's just a big green
box of organic
vegetables which nobody wants nobody
well some people want that and that's
that's fine but this is actually meal
kit so
which is what i want yes ingredients
come pre-measured mostly
prepped so you'll spend less time
stressing more time
enjoying delicious home-cooked meals
plus they offer
100 offset of their direct carbon
emissions
and their plastic packaging so you can
feel good about what you're getting and
how it got to your table to sign up go
to greenchef.com
what if 90 and use the code what if 90
to get 90 off 90 bucks
off yeah plus free shipping yeah so
that's green
chef dot com slash what if 90 use the
code what if 90 to get 90
off including free shipping or free
shipping
or green chefing green chef
the number one meal kit for eating well
so professor it's been 25 years since
you
and your team made that discovery
obviously we know technology changes
at a crazy exponential rate pretty much
year to year these days i we hear about
things like the dynamite model we hear
other sort of new introductions to this
search for other planets
what is some of the technology and new
science
that exists in the field of discovering
new exoplanets
well we have improved quite a lot
the tools that we were using at that
time to detect planet
well first the machine that measured the
radial velocity or the speed of the star
the
the accuracy or the precision we get
with the measurements
has increased by factor 100 because we
have been using plenty of new techniques
optics component
now we have been flying satellites that
have been pretty efficient
about finding planet one of the famous
one is kepler the kepler missions
right now there is a test satellite and
the k up satellite flying
and sooner there will be the plato
satellite so all this is a new
development that help us to find
smaller planets or planets on different
kind of star
but the big change is coming with the
new generations
of very large telescopes so we and say
the community
the astrophysical community in the world
are building
the next generations of telescopes the
size of the mirror of this telescope
will range
from 30 meter to 40 meter diameter
which are really huge it's a massive
progress it's a complete new kind of
technology
and with this machine we will be able to
make
a picture of some of this planet and
talking about space in less than a year
we will be flying the next
space telescope which is a gems web
space telescopes and with this telescope
we are going to measure atmosphere
of some of this transiting planet that
we have found
especially the small ones for which we
will have
a lot of questions to ask because we
have little idea
all this uh what we call super earth
planet
or really have been formed and what they
look like and
we will have a lot of surprises and good
ones i can tell
you wow just uh just so you know dda the
the 30 meter uh mirror is what richard
uses to get ready
yeah every morning that's what it it
requires me to get ready for the show
with 30 meter
mirror um you've been on record as
playing down the possibility of us
uh one day migrating to an exoplanet and
that's probably because of the distance
but let's say we get in our what if time
machine and richard if you can give me a
little bit of sound effects
and we've solved the practical issue of
getting there so
we get there then what what if
well i think we should acknowledge that
it's unlikely we'll go there
any time but it doesn't matter i think
you can look at the earth
without going to the earth we have
plenty of satellite that is
looking at the earth so what you can
retrieve
by remote looking at something
is just absolutely amazing so we will
look
with amazing details on this planet and
we will know whether they have a surface
we will know what kind of rocks
are on the surface we don't need to go
there to get an idea what it is
we will know whether that is water it's
pretty easy to detect water
and make very strong spectral signature
we will know whether
the planet rotates we will know whether
there are continents
all this will be possible remotely and
we may have
evidence from the chemistry of the
atmosphere that
something is going on on this planet
that cannot be only explained by
let's say the geophysics of the planet
and it must be related to life
and this is the most exciting i think
prospect that we have
that possibly and it's not in a so far
future
we may have a clear evidence that
their alive on some of this planet
or maybe there is no life on this planet
and that's really a big question and i
think this will tell us a lot about
ourselves
because so far is quite amazing that
we are on one of the systems that looks
pretty much
different from all the planet that we
have found so
is it the reason why they are live
because we are different
or it's just a matter of luck here and i
think this kind of question we should be
able to answer
i mean it's it's hard to overstate how
wildly exciting
these times are and you know what
when you look back in a thousand years
on this particular time in history it
will be
the beginning of an entirely new era
professor honestly that's
there's so much more to talk about you
talked about the possibilities of
discovering intelligent life in the
universe we haven't gotten to even talk
about
uh the the fantastic netflix series
alien worlds which you are obviously a
big part of which
helps us imagine what some of these
exoplanets might look like
if there was life there it's so highly
recommended we want to talk about that
and more on the other side of the break
professor can you stick around
i can fantastic we'll be back more with
professor
kelo yeah if you want to hear more with
the nobel prize winning astronomer ddl
didier quello
click on the link below and you can get
the full audio podcast
of the show if you're already listening
to it well we'll be back after the break
um and professor before we let
our viewers go uh maybe you can tell
them where they can find your work
online or anywhere else well i think if
you google my name
you will be amazing how many movies and
recording there are of my talks of my
work so just just use the google
search machine yeah a quick google
search on the old magic box
all right so for those of you who are
ready to go further into space
click that link and if that's all the
time you have for us well thanks for
joining us
on what if discussed